u bahnlinie 2 hamburg haltestelle
emilienstraße ein bahnsteig ein kiosk
aber kein gewöhnlicher mit zeitungen und
süßigkeiten für die vorbeikommenden hat
der mann im kiosk ein ganz besonderes
angebot nichts kaufen kann man sich zu
hören lassen
ich bin ganz ohr wenn eine geschichte
erzählen wollen oder auch nur ein paar
sätze ich nehme alles einfach zuhören
das macht neugierig die leute bleiben
stehen an christoph busch zuhörer kiosk
in der u bahn
ich würde mich freuen wenn die man
vorbei kommen da steht auch eine
telefonnummer
das wird dann vielleicht ein buch aber
vor allen dingen wäre ich erst mal zu
der 71 jährige ist drehbuchautor für das
fernsehen
eigentlich hat er den ungewöhnlichen ort
als schreibstube gemietet mir
vorgestellt dass ich hier sitze und
schreibe und ab und zu spricht mich mal
jemand an oder ich spreche jemanden an
und ich will eine neue geschichte und
zum schreiben komme ich eigentlich nicht
mehr ich will nur noch zu die meisten
leute denen christoph busch sein ohr
leiht wollen aber nicht vor die kamera
sie erzählen aus ihrer kindheit episoden
oder ihr ganzes leben und sie freuen
sich dass jemand für sie da ist die
tatsache dass man normalerweise nicht in
die u bahn stationen geht und dazu
bleiben bedeutet auch wegen jemand
hierhin kommt dann ist er extra gekommen
unter zeit mitgebracht
und da ist
hallo
ich habe sie auf dem zettel sie hatte
sich telefonisch angemeldet und erzählt
von ihrer ehe mit einem weniger lesen
christoph busch spürt nach könnte das
eine spannende geschichte werden
damals irgendwie bin ich in senegal
ausgewandert mit meinem mann zusammen
und er war da nicht so überzeugt ich
habe gesagt nein das machen wir und ich
habe so viele ideen und das ist ein
armes land wir müssen ja gut die ideen
reinbringen das schaffen wir
dreiviertel jahr zurück ja das war eine
tolle erfahrung ich halte schon ausschau
nach menschen die ich normalerweise so
nicht kennen lernt also die nicht
unbedingt bei mir zu hause aus die party
kommen würden sogar auch leute geben mir
einen gewissen respekt einflößen oder wo
ich denke was der wohl sagt oder die
aber das reizt mich frage ersatz sein
für einen therapeuten oder seelsorger
will er aber nicht dennoch hört er hier
mehr üble geschichten als schöne ich
sage mir immer zum glück ist das
gegenteil von glück und wenn man kein
unglück hat weiß man gar nicht was glück
ist und die leute die hier hinkommen
wollen aller meister aus ihrem unglück
raus und dann ist es hier so ein kleiner
erster schritt um zu gucken wie ich
schaffe ich das
viele geschichten gehen christoph busch
na dann kann ja gar nicht anders als
abends das nach hause mitzunehmen was
die anderen ihm da gelassen haben